-Movie.
-Okay. Um...
-Two words.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Second word.
-Yeah.
-Me.
You.
Me.
Boy. Boy.
Man.
First word.
[ Laughter ]
Fly man?
Oh, Spider-Man?
Oh, Batman.
Gosh, I can't think of --
Ant-Man!
-Yes!
-Yes! Ant-Man!
♪♪♪♪
Now, we all know
how to play "Charades."
We're gonna do four rounds
30 seconds on the clock
per round.
Then the fifth round
is the showdown.
Both teams get the same clue
at the same time.
I will go first.
You guys
can all take your seats.
All right, Saoirse,
you're over here.
Come on.
-Where are we going? This way?
-Yeah, you're on that side
All right now.
Here we go.
Come on, pal, we got this.
What number, guys?
-Three!
[ Audience shouting "Three"
-Wow, everyone just said
"three."
"Three!" Everyone's like,
"Yeah, okay, cool, three."
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, okay.
-Mm-hmm.
-Telepathy, Jimmy.
Telepathy.
-We got this.
-We got this, pardsy.
Let's go. Ready?
-We're soul brother and sister
-All right, ready?
-Yeah.
Is it a song?
-Yes.
-It's a song.
-Okay.
-Okay, three words.
Okay.
First word, baby.
Third word.
"Baby Got Back."
-Yes, that's correct!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You want to go first?
Yeah, you go first.
That was too easy.
-Alessia --
No, Alessia, you're up first
-Oh, I have to go first?
Oh, okay.
-Put the pressure on you.
[ Audience shouting ]
-Seven?
"Seven!"
Going for lucky number seven
I feel like I'm on, like -
-"The Tonight Show"!
-Come on!
No, I don't want this one.
I don't want this one.
-Alessia, you have to do it.
-Exactly.
-I don't want this one.
-You have to do it.
-Don't show us, though.
-All right.
Okay, so it's...
-TV.
-Okay.
-Four words.
-Is this timed? We have time
-Yes!
-Oh, shoot. Okay.
Okay, wait, wait.
Um, um, um -- come on!
Okay, okay, thir-- oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Third word.
-Um...
-Fighting.
Ninja warrior.
Ninja --
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Yes! Okay.
I never thought
you were gonna get that.
-That is rigged!
-It's fun! It's fun.
-That's fun.
-How did you get that,
and then you end up
with a floss at the end?
-That was amazing.
-It's fine.
-Just be chill.
-All right, sorry.
I'm gonna be cool.
-All right?
-I'm gonna be cool.
-We're winners.
-All right, we're winners.
Here we go.
[ Audience shouting ]
-I see -- I see a two.
Oh!
-That's good.
-Don't look!
-Disqualified.
-What we do?
-That's a point off.
-We'll take two.
-Okay.
-We're winners. Here we go
-We're champions.
-Right.
-Legends.
Movie.
-Okay. Um...
-Two words.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Second word.
-Yeah.
-Me.
You.
Me.
Boy. Boy.
Man.
First word.
[ Laughter ]
Fly man?
Oh, Spider-Man?
Oh, Batman.
Gosh, I can't think of --
Ant-Man!
-Yes!
-Yes! Ant-Man!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Anderson,
let's see what you got.
-What are we gonna
do about this?
-You can do that.
Do you want to do that one
-Don't look, don't look.
-Do you want to do that one?
-No.
No, we don't do the fallen one
-All right.
[ Audience shouting ]
-Yeah?
-Got this.
-All right.
-It's easy.
-I don't know. Okay.
-Okay.
-No, me, me, me. Not --
-Okay, it's a song.
-Mm-hmm.
-Three words.
Um...
Shoot.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
Uh...
-First word.
Third word.
Cry.
-Mm-hmm.
-Bird?
[ Light laughter ]
Pray?
Cry.
Fly, cry --
I don't know!
[ Laughter ]
Wait.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-"Living on a Prayer"?
[ Laughing ]
Oh, my gosh.
-"When Doves Cry"?
-"When Doves Cry"!
[ Ding! ]
-Prince!
-No.
-He had the moves, then pointed.
-I was trying to do the ass --
-He pointed
at the butt cheeks.
That was a good move.
-Wow, I'm sorry.
-I should've
showed my butt cheek.
-Yeah, you should have.
That would have --
-I got it.
-Damn it.
Here we go.
You guys have a chance.
This is the final round.
-Wait.
So, are we tied?
-No, we're in the lead,
but, Saoirse and Alessia,
you guys are gonna get
the same clue at the same time
and whatever team gets it,
wins the whole game.
We get to guess,
you guys get to do the charades.
-Oh.
-So we have to do the same one
-Yep.
-Okay. What number do you want
[ Audience shouting ]
She does have moves.
-Let's do 5.
-5, yeah.
-I saw the moves.
-Oh.
[ Laughing ]
-Okay, wait.
One, two, three, four, five.
[ Laughter ]
All right.
Ready?
-Pal, we got this.
-Wait. Are we going?
-Yeah, we're going!
-Okay.
-First word.
Bang.
-Last word.
-Open. Drop.
-First word.
Uh, fall.
Uh...
-Five.
Fifth word.
Taste.
-Drop.
-Sizzle.
-Drop --
-"Drop it like it's hot"!
Ohh! Ohh! Ohh!
Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh!
Ohh, my goodness!
-Hold on!
-♪♪ Drop it like it's hot
♪♪ Drop it like it's hot ♪♪
Yes, yes!
Whoo!
Our thanks to Saoirse Ronan,
Alessia Cara, Anderson .Paak
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, you all know
how to play "Charades."
Each player gets a turn giving
silent clues to their teammate
45 seconds
on the clock per turn.
We'll do four rounds
worth one point each.
The fifth round
is the "Charades" showdown
Each team gets the same clue
to give at the same time,
and whoever guesses it
first gets 2 points.
Ho ho.
[ Laughter ]
Ewan, why don't you
start us out tonight?
Charles and me,
we'll go over here.
-Right.
-Jeff, you can sit there.
-All right.
Charles, which side do you like?
-It doesn't matter.
Don't make me look bad, Jimmy.
-I won't.
I'm not going to.
Oh, you're up first.
-What do I do?
-Oh, sorry.
Yeah, you take a --
Sorry about that.
-I'll just make one up?
-Yeah, yeah, no.
Take one off the board.
-Okay.
-They've got magnets.
The audience can help, too
Or you can take your own.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Whatever you want to do.
7 it is.
Right. And I do it
just to my team?
-You're gonna give it to Jeff.
-Yeah.
-And you throw it
in that box -- that shelf.
There you go.
-Okay.
[ Clears throat ]
Okay.
Is it timed?
-Yes.
-Okay. Ready? And...
-Movie.
Two word -- three words?
-Oh, my God!
Oh, my gosh!
You're off to a bad start, dude!
Gosh!
He's doing it the English way!
-Okay, okay.
-There you go.
Okay, this one.
-No, no, no, no!
[ Laughter ]
-This is --
-This airs in America!
-Three words, three words.
-This one.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't want to do that.
It's the middle one.
-It's the middle one.
It's small -- "The."
It, iv, if, it, is, uh...
[ Laughter ]
It's a wheel.
-All right.
-First word.
Um...
[ Laughter ]
Wed-- Bride.
Okay.
[ Buzzer ]
-Ohh!
-"The Princess Bride."
-Bride --
"Bride of Frankenstein"?
-You know, you've seen them.
-No, I haven't seen them.
-Okay, yes, you're right.
-Oh. Sorry.
-I shouldn't spend
so much time on "of."
[ Laughter ]
-I've not seen them!
I've seen them?
You made that up.
I didn't see anything.
-You've been here all day.
You could've looked at them.
-A theme here.
I've been here all day
but not actually here.
[ Audience shouting ]
Why did everyone yell 4?
Like you know.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
[ Indistinct talking ]
-Movie.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-Uh...
-Four words.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-Three words.
-No, sorry.
[ Laughter ]
You've played "Charades" before,
have you not?
-Yes! Yes! Yes.
-Mm.
-Three letters.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, ready?
So...
-Four words.
-Yeah.
-Four words, movie.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey.
"Karate Kid."
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-Four words!
[ Laughter ]
-"The Kara--"
That's three words, Jimmy.
-No, no! Well,
"The Karate Kid's" three, but...
-Why'd you say four?
-Because I said the third word
was "ninja!"
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That was your clue?!
-That was a ninja!
Yeah! That was a ninja!
-Are you kidding me?
-That was a ninja right there.
-That -- Listen.
That was awful.
-All right.
[ Laughter ]
Zero-zero.
-That was awful.
-Get ready.
Get ready for awful.
[ Audience shouting ]
"Karate Kid."
[ Laughter ]
-Book.
-He's too calm.
[ Laughter ]
-Five words.
-Oh.
"Karate Kid."
[ Laughter ]
"Part 2."
-Fourth word.
Out of five.
The fifth word.
Hat. Top hat. Hat.
Just hat.
"The Man who Mistook
His Wife for a Hat." No.
[ Laughter ]
Those are the kind of book
I read.
Two, second word.
Beard.
Mustache.
Wind, horse, cat.
Goat, horse, cat.
Cat, cat.
"The Cat In The Hat."
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-Come on, Charles!
You can do on it, my man!
Come on.
We can do it.
-You're awful.
-No, I'm not awful!
You can't say that
going into it.
That's a bad attitude.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience shouting ]
-Eight?
-Yeah, we can do this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Um...
-You can put that -- You can
put that in there if you want.
All right.
Okay.
-Um...
-Don't -- Don't talk.
Don't talk.
Singing.
It's a song.
How many words?
Uh, wait!
I know what he means!
"Frozen!"
No.
[ Laughter ]
Cold.
Chilly.
"Do You Want
to Build a Snowman?" No.
First word.
First word -- chill.
Ooh. Chilly, cold, uh, uh,
temperature down.
Cold, drinking,
Russia, Russian.
No. Shots, sho--
Shots, chilling.
What do you take?
Booze, liquor, shot,
booze, Jagermeister.
Whiskey.
What's in the shot?
What's in there?
Whiskey.
Whiskey mixer.
Cocktail, cocktail.
[ Buzzer ]
-Vanilla Ice, "Ice Ice Baby"
-The hell is that?!
-Cold! Ice!
That's not what he does
in "Ice Ice Baby"!
-It was cold!
-Couldn't you do, like --
do like a thing and do lik
a Vanilla Ice kind of thing.
-Don't do that again.
-I won't do it again.
I'm sorry.
All right, this is it.
Hey, that was -- that was --
That was awful.
All right, here we go.
Now this is the showdown here.
'Cause what's the score now?
-1-nil.
-It's 1-0.
So here's the deal --
whoever wins this
wins the whole thing.
-Okay, good luck.
-Here we go.
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
We can do this.
-We can do this.
Ready?
-What number are we doing?
-What would you like?
-Good luck.
What number? 5?
-Sure.
No, they like 10.
-Number 10.
-Wait.
Are we gonna guess the same?
-Yep.
-Okay.
-So we're doing that.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Ready?
-Okay.
-One word.
Movie.
Uh, uh...
-No, uh, Leo DiCaprio!
Um, um!
"Titanic"!
[ Dinging ]
-Charles Barkley said it!
Charles Barkley had it!
Charles Barkley!
[ Laughs ]
We got it!
[ Laughing ]
-We need a replay.
-No replay!
Charles Barkley right there!
"Titanic"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And he gave the actor,
which is bonus points!
We win, 300-1!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Our thanks to Ewan McGregor,
Jeff Tweedy, Charles Barkley
"Titanic"!